Speaker 1: All right. Let's get to some of
your emails, tweets, Reddit posts, smoke signals
and telegrams that have come in over the last
week or so. You can always email info at David
Packman dot com if you have feedback for us.
And let's just get right into it. Melvin Peachy
came. I don't know why I find that name funny.
Melvin Peachy says, Dude, you need Jesus.
How can you mock people and their faith? There
is t h e r e, which is the wrong there? Listen,
Jesus is not for me mocking people and their
faith. Listen, this is not about mocking anything
that brings meaning to individuals. When we
get to a point in society.
Speaker 3: Where beliefs.
Speaker 1: That make no sense literally are
being imposed on civil government to make
law, then I have a problem. And yes, I may
on some level mock those beliefs there. When
it comes to private religious views. If you
want to privately believe in Noah's Ark or
the.
Speaker 3: Zoos.
Speaker 1: Or Thor, or that, you know, a Jewish
carpenter was the son of God born to a virgin,
died then came back to life and walked on
water or whatever. If you want to privately
believe that and not impose it in any way
on civil governance and the way that this
country runs. Okay, Go ahead and do it right.
I mean, I don't think it's accurate, but go
ahead and do it. But the second that these
right wing extremists introduce religious
justifications for telling women what they
are allowed to do with their bodies, in consultation
with doctors, as well as I guess your your
sacred texts now are part of the consultation.
No. And at that point, we're going to say
this doesn't make any sense. And I don't believe
that the left should apologize for that. Believe
whatever you want to believe. But don't not
only don't impose it on others. Don't use
it as a justification for civil government
to run in any particular way. And that is
absolutely my position. Creaks in says about
the mass shootings that we continue to have
in the United States. We've become numb to
all of this horror. That in itself is an indictment
of American culture and government policy.
I could not agree more, and this is something
I was recently I was recently interviewed
for a forthcoming written profile, which I'll
share with you when it's published. And the
topic of sort of becoming desensitized to
insanity came up. And I do everything I can.
As someone who covers a lot of these sorts
of things on a daily basis, I do everything
I can not to become desensitized. And, you
know, during Trump, by the thousands time
thousandth time that he does something bonkers,
like using a Sharpie to draw on a hurricane
map or sending a reporter out of the room
like they're being sent to the principal's
office. It's important to fight normalization
and hyper normalization of crazy things, and
I try to remind myself of that. But I admit.
It can be tough not to become desensitized
to some degree. And the mass shootings, I
mean, on any day of the week, you can go to
gun violence archive and look at the last
72 hours and you'll see individual gun homicides
and mass shootings every single day. And sometimes
they don't even really make the news. It's
an absolutely terrifying reality. But it is
where we are right now, and we have to find
a way to do something about it. Posted to
the David Pakman Show Subreddit by Lochner.
Asking Opinion on Tulsi Gabbard as Trump's
VP pick writing. I think Tulsi might be an
option for Trump's VP pick as she would fulfill
the requirement of being a woman as well as
being a Russia Putin apologist. I think her
not being white could easily be spun into
a positive for racist right wingers. She's
proven to have no limit when it comes to debasing
herself for her own personal gain and might
pick up some low information voters that still
think she has some credibility or integrity.
The whole being disillusioned with and leaving
the Democratic Party could be turned into
a strength. Most of all, I think she fits
Trump's image requirement that he wants someone
that looks like they're from central casting.
I'm not trying to be sexist myself, writes
Lochner. But looking at the situation from
Trump's perspective and how image obsessed
he is, I don't think he'd go for someone like
Marjorie Taylor GREENE for that reason. Nikki
Haley, I guess, would be the most obvious
choice. But I really think the possibility
exists for Tulsi to get picked. I'd probably
put her before Cory, like anyway, with her
just basically being a sore loser. Anybody
else think this is possible? Yeah. I mean,
so I have two thoughts on this one. I don't
believe Tulsi Gabbard is going to be Trump's
VP pick, but I agree with all of the reasoning
that Lochner lays out for why Tulsi would
actually fit. Check a lot of the boxes. She
would be a I'm reading the late David Graeber's
book, B.S. Jobs, and he talks about one category
of best jobs is box checkers, so to speak.
And Tulsi checks a lot of the boxes. She's
not tough on Putin, which works well for Trump.
She has, even though the right now says they're
against identity politics, she actually checks
some identity boxes that would allow those
on the right to say, see, we're not sexist,
we're not racist. It's a nonwhite woman. I
mean, I guess I guess Tulsi Gabbard is not
white. It's not totally clear. She's half
she's native Hawaiian, I think, or Native
Native American. I'm not actually sure. I
don't do the identity thing, so I'm actually
not sure what the deal is with that. She left
the left, which is super popular. You know,
Dave Room Ruben made a bunch of money by leaving
left and so she has that. I agree 100% for
a bunch of reasons. Tulsi would be a great
pick for Trump. I don't think she is who Trump
is going to go for. From the YouTube channel
Dynamic Photography says about gun violence,
there was an insane amount of murders by stabbings
and vehicular impact over the weekend as well.
Are we going to discuss banning knifes, knives
and vehicles as well? News flash, we need
to get to the bottom of our mental health
epidemic ASAP. It's way deeper than the tool
that's used. Well, again, we need to do both.
I am with everybody on the right who says
we need to deal with the mental health crisis
in this country. It would be nice if some
of the right wing are saying that we're willing
to actually put some money towards funding
dealing with the mental health crisis. Many
of them are not willing to do that. But I
will go further. If we have mentally ill people,
some of whom are prone to violence as the
right loves to say, and they might have access
to knives, vehicles and guns, wouldn't we
want to restrict their access to guns? Like
do we want mentally ill people predisposed
to violence to have a AR 15? Now, you could
say, well, they also shouldn't have a knife.
They're going to be able to kill way more
people in a short period of time with an AR
15 than they are with a knife. And then, you
know, often they go to this vehicle thing.
Yeah, you can use vehicles as a weapon, but
vehicles primarily have a completely different
purpose that is not to shoot people. Oh, but
guns can be used for target practice. Okay.
Yeah, but the the primary function of the
history of a firearm was as a tool of war
and as a tool of killing, not as a tool of
target practice. Primary function of a vehicle
is transportation. And so they get all mixed
up about it. It's kind of sad to see, but
we've got to keep rebutting it because they
keep saying it. Matt White's posted to our
Facebook page. Conservatives time after time
come around only when it happens to them.
They are binary. Zero sum immediate gratification
thinkers without the capacity for empathy
until it lands on their lap. I am afraid that
the majority of gun fetish visors and Second
Amendment contortionists will keep at it until
the accumulative corrosive effects on society
force their hands. By then, it may be too
late for civil America. Yeah, I mean, we've
seen many anti-gay Republicans who all of
a sudden their nephew comes out or their daughter
and they change their view. And unfortunately,
that's going to take too long. And it's impractical
when it comes to waiting around for that to
happen with gun violence. It just doesn't
make sense. And it would be an insane amount
of death and destruction. So I think I think
the comment is correct. Personally facing
gun violence might change the views of some
of these Republicans. Some would not change
their minds. But we can't rely on that as
a way to fix the problem. Frederick Simon
has said on Facebook. I'm sorry to say it,
but I think a lot of American people are willing
to destroy the country because they think
Biden will not make it through the entire
next presidential term if he wins and the
vice president would take over. This is the
only reason I can think of, because if Trump
wins, we know where the country would be headed.
A dictatorship? Yeah. Listen, I'm not 100%
sure I understand this one, but I wanted to
include it because there there is something
really important here. Would trump turn the
U.S. into a dictatorship if he could? I think
it's plausible that he would. You know, when
George W Bush said this would be a lot easier
if it was a dictatorship or whatever the case
may be. I don't think Bush would turn the
country into a dictatorship given the opportunity.
I do believe that Trump actually would, but
I don't believe he's going to really get that
opportunity. And I know every time I say this,
people write to me, they say, David, that's
dangerous for you to say that because you're
minimizing that. No, no, no, no, no. I'm not
minimizing the threat. I've been crystal clear
about the dangers presented by Trump. I do
not believe that if Trump got four more years,
he would turn the U.S. into a dictatorship,
even if that would be his preference. If you
disagree with me, let me know. Michael wrote
in with a podcast question as Hey David, Mike
here, long time viewer, first time emailer.
I saw you on Lex Friedman's podcast, which
is great. I've been watching both of you forever.
It made me wonder when someone like you does
a podcast such as his is there payment involved?
For that matter, Do any podcast guests get
compensated or do people view it as an opportunity
to get their name out there? Thanks in advance.
Okay. We have never paid any of the thousand
plus guests who we have interviewed, and I
have never been paid to be on any podcast
either. That being said, we have been asked
for payment a couple of times by guests. I
won't tell you who they were. They actually
weren't really big names. It's interesting.
The really big names seem to understand you
either do it or you don't. It's either worth
doing or you don't. You either have time for
it or you don't. But you don't. You don't
ask for money. Middle high level guests. Are
the ones who have asked for money in the past.
Is this a paid appearance? We would do it.
And the answer is always no. And I believe
this is basically always the case. Now, the
exception to this would be if you get invited,
like right now, for example, I'm in the middle
of talking with a it's not a podcast. It's
a show that films in a different part of the
country. And. There. They do offer compensation.
It's not a podcast appearance. It's sort of
a program that is being cast. And there's
an there's a fee and they pay travel. It's
sort of a different thing. But as far as podcasts
like ours, we have never paid anyone. I have
never been paid and I have never heard of
anyone being paid. Okay. Richard Harris commented
on YouTube. I find it incredible that so many
Americans could even contemplate voting for
Republican candidates after what we've seen
of Republican policies, particularly with
regard to abortion and other health care issues,
is stupidity or ignorance mostly to blame?
Well, stupidity and ignorance are kind of
the same thing. I think the better question
is, are is is it stupidity? Is it selfishness
or is it a complete disregard for other people
that is to blame? And I think the answer is
it's a combination of all of those things.
And I've spoken about this extensively before,
and unless we deal with all three of those
aspects, I worry we're not going to be able
to get out of this sort of doom stupidity
cycle in which we find ourselves today. Let
me know what you think. Stupidity, stupidity,
selfishness or lack of lack of concern for
others. Which is more to blame in what proportions?
Send in your emails info at David Pakman dot
com. Remember that Monday Memorial Day we'll
be doing a one day membership special. It's
going to be explosive like nothing you've
ever seen before. If you've been thinking,
maybe I'll sign up. I don't know. It sounds
kind of interesting. Monday, Memorial Day
is a great day to do it. All you need to do
in order to be notified about the Monday membership
special is to get on our newsletter at David
Patricof. We'll see you on the bonus show.
We'll see you back on Monday.